this has gone viral another awkward
exchange between Don Lemon and his
female co-hosts when lemon tries to
criticize Nikki Haley and manages to do
to do it in a way that that offends even
his leftist co-host let's watch how that
goes she says people you know
politicians are something and not in
their Prime Nikki Haley is in a prime
sorry when a woman is considered being
her Prime in her 20s and 30s and maybe
40s that's not according to me fighting
for what it depends I mean it's just
like Prime if you look it up it'll if
you look if you Google when is a woman
in her prime it'll say 20s 30s and 40s
nothing I agree with that are you
talking about Prime for like child
see the look on his face that he
realized he stepped in it
just look at Google Google said it what
are you talking about I can guarantee
you that Don Lemon voted for Hillary
Clinton in 2016. it was in her like late
60s at the time